wo ist dein weg
[Musik]
beschreiben sie sich mit eigenen worten
um die partnersuche zu erleichtern
mein name ist 75 jahre alt aber trotzdem
noch sehr aktiv
ich bin für alles offen
naja lama und suche eine sportliche was
du bei der bank ja ich war aber der bank
und es gibt ja immer noch irgendein
problem hast du ja ich habe alle
wichtigen formulare ausgefüllt trotzdem
schaffen sie es nicht um eine
überweisung zu bearbeiten ich verstehe
das wirklich nicht aber du musst doch
die übernachtung und die fahrt heute
noch bezahlt weiß ich weiß
es tut mir leid das ist so peinlich ist
lade ich dich ein und und dann passiert
so was aber wenn die bank das problem
nicht lösen kann müssen wir stornieren
auf keinen fall du hast vielleicht
probleme mit deiner bank trotzdem fahren
wir ein paar tage weg ja ich kann die
reise doch bezahlen
das ist kein problem auf keinen fall du
bist kein fremder aus dem internet ich
habe dich nicht in irgendeinem
partnerportal kennengelernt ich kenne
dich lange genug
ich vertraue dir natürlich
also ich bezahle die reise keine
diskussion wenn du unbedingt willst
kannst du mir das geld zurückgeben wenn
du die probleme mit der bank gelöst ist
einverstanden einverstanden